[Music]
in Nice Chinese
nice try but me they submitted by
American sushi California roll elephant
or Philadelphia roll Philadelphia okay
without or what if it's not like a sushi
sushi well what else would be American
Americans so like a burrito sushi Reno
yeah what is that
never had a sister ito literally like a
sushi ingredient burrito just rolled up
like a burrito I like sushi
a white guy tried to use a home DNA test
to qualify as a minority business owner
this reminds me of [ __ ] South Park
when they [ __ ] with 23andme and then he
makes out with a Native American 23 me
so he could prove that he's indigenous
as genius it came back that he was just
so he could claim that he's like like
Native and all that [ __ ] damn that's
[ __ ] genius but the funny thing is
you didn't even get the guy just fitted
with to form you got the [ __ ] hard it
was really fighting yeah so this guy's
name is Ralph Taylor he's 55 years old
this is what he looks like
oh damn I was like Steve Greene's dad
this dude he got a home DNA test back in
2010 and he was saying that the DNA test
showed that he is 90% white Caucasian 6%
indigenous American and 4% sub-saharan
African oh cool oh he's black now so he
is a small business owner of a car
insurance company and so he wanted to
apply for a minority business
certificate which allows minorities mark
minority businesses to release extra
contracts to kind of like level the
playing field
yeah in the transportation industry for
minorities okay like this guy he's funny
so he was denied the certificate because
under the US Department of
Transportation program he is still
considered a Caucasian yes the
department that's one
like as a black person no denied they
were probably like are you [ __ ]
kidding me
yeah so then now he's pursuing well this
is like a box of a pile of applicants
that are the same thing why so many
people doing that now yeah now he's
suing oh my god
yeah for what because of his six percent
no he's suing like the whole like the
way that they determine who is a
minority you see where they [ __ ] up
they didn't do a thorough investigation
because there's some white people that
are more minority than minorities are so
you got to go to his house and you got
to [ __ ] really see how this person
lives and you're like what do you mean
what white people are more minority than
minorities yeah like does he claim to
really be like like what he says he is
because he's eating the meals of a
sub-sahara yeah like if you go in there
and you're like oh [ __ ] you know what he
is his you know and and it's like did he
grow up with a [ __ ] abusive father
did he grow up little are you related
though no but then the main like
argument of like the the different
disenfranchised are like why the
minority needs to get like some type of
leg up and all that stuff is because in
most cases minorities do come from a
lesser part of town and less education
and they just need to level the playing
field because for generations it's been
[ __ ] up right so then in that with
that like kind of like similarity in his
situation if you go to his house in your
life hmm is he really messy can let's
check and you go over there in your life
yup his wife is beating his kid with a
slipper check what are they well you
know like this book got tucking alright
check you know like you got a check like
is this really what you say did you go
over there and it's like a super like
suburban white home and [ __ ] and then
you you feel like the Flanders live here
you're like don't try to fool me yeah
investigation well this is that he's
suing for the way that they like
determine if who is a minority right so
like how is there is that what's his
alternative this is an employee at the
certification company stated he said it
is or they said it is nonsensical for
mr. Taylor to claim that he has
encountered social and economic
disadvantage due to a heritage he was
not aware of until the DNA test
conducted in 2010 yeah because there
have been other people there like in
this article they're saying that there
was this one person that did qualify for
that program and he was white but he
acknowledged that he had never been been
disenfranchised so this person said that
he qualified for both the state and
federal programs that he's about six
percent african-american but he looks
Caucasian so he's never encountered
discrimination she was more honest with
this application so he got it but this
guy is a [ __ ] liar he's in my whole
life I've faced discrimination that's
why didn't gave it something well I
don't know if he said that but that's
what's the implying I feel like they
should take this case by case because
there are like literally if you're
ninety percent white you don't qualify I
don't know no there's no case because in
my land I would do it like this okay
because there are rich as black people
there are rich as Mexicans there are
rich as Asians and everybody else that
hasn't really been through [ __ ] but they
qualify for this [ __ ] and automatically
because of your race you get a hat you
get whatever right because your group
has been [ __ ] up but then you
personally never went through some [ __ ]
but you do qualify that's not fair how
do you test that out that's why I'm like
I would do a thorough investigation
there's gotta be a cheers to that we're
parents all crack yes check maybe you
could be like you could be white as hell
but if you're we want to see [ __ ] all
you have to do is just make it income ya
know I can't be just income based though
I want to hear the struggle it's like
and then I wanna I want a bidding war of
like who had it worse but then how do
you know who's telling the truth and
who's lying investigations damn you're
gonna pay a lot of [ __ ] money and it's
gonna be like a year process
well it doesn't be about
[ __ ] something went through but it could
also be like yeah fine they came from a
very well-off family but even in their
circle of friends maybe they also faced
you know disenfranchising or whatever I
want a child soldier that [ __ ]
survived and swam to America from Burma
and they were like a straight-a student
they were schooling their own teachers
and [ __ ] they just [ __ ] killed it
and they went through so much [ __ ] so
you're not trying to help anyone but
like 0.5% I'm trying to help out the
best the chosen one [ __ ] best
the chosen well then they might not need
to apply for this because if they're the
chosen one they might already be
successful at all they needed was a
little bit of helping money that's what
I'm saying and then it's like here but
you already know how to fish here's just
a little bit of money and you're gonna
[ __ ] build great things my friend all
right well funny part that they
mentioned in this article that he stated
that he subscribed to every magazine oh
my god I'm double ACP you remember keep
going and I wear my hat sideways my
middle name is Dominique my friends call
me lil we've got mail laddie he also
provided DNA results and a 1916 death
certificate of a black woman but
officials could not determine whether he
was related oh my god screwin it for all
of them related to her you're right
that's like the the natives in Oklahoma
that we met that looked like 99% white
people what's that what's the real
what's the real intention though of like
this guy applying for this ultimately
it's his attention is like he wants to
get the benefits of having extra
contracts because he has a conscience
Milius money right yeah yeah
pardon me take the devil's advocate
chronic perspective but like what's the
difference between somebody for example
trying to evade like California state
taxes by saying that they're gonna
incorporate their business in like
Delaware okay it's the same thing it's
pretty much the same thing it's the same
thing but he just wasn't able to go
along with his loophole plan yeah but
ultimately it's not like you know you're
a terrible it's just really
disrespectful because it's a minority
thing and it's a white guy so if he had
gone another way to like scam the system
that wasn't directly affecting right now
I feel like it's like this okay what if
there was a grant for [ __ ] legless
humans because they can't walk you know
what I mean it's like legless legless
business owners right and this was like
well I technically Conda am legless
cause I ain't got toes and it's like boy
we could still walk [ __ ] no you
shouldn't you shouldn't get that money
he got toes and then you got real
legless people gotta like hella hard to
tell like how how would somebody lose
all their toes but say that must have
been like a big toe I knew someone that
lost their toes or like tired no not all
ten her husband lost it cuz she had
diabetes I mean he had diabetes and they
had to like I know they had to amputate
my uncle kind of did a loophole like
this where he overheard that the
citizenship test was easier for
handicapped people so he walked into the
office like limping inactive took the
test for the handicapped you got a
citizenship why would it be easier I
don't know well that's all my dad's well
my dad's like he's like you know your
third uncle he's [ __ ] crazy he's
gonna do this maybe it's just more
difficult for him to learn better you
can walk the school fast enough so you
had to miss two three days out of the
week
oh my god I just think it's it's it's
[ __ ] up because he's taking well he if
he did get this grant or whatever right
he didn't that's what he's doing
yeah but he he could have taken it away
from other people well I'm done
[Music]